hi guys I'm gonna be playing Serena for
you today it's like a short horror
point-and-click but it's more horror is
in the atmospheres eerie and tense and
dark you probably know why now that I
really like that kind of stuff I like
the fact that it's been a collaborative
effort between like fans and designers
of adventure games
sometimes when I make a great effort i
can remember her scent the sweetness of
her breath Serena
good whoo okay this is interesting so
I'm like writing the game oh okay oh but
her face missing what did you do with
her face Serena why can't I see you more
clearly I can't i okay so I'm guessing
just just a random guess yeah I'm
guessing that this is either he killed
her or he has like some forward dementia
should be very sad and vanishing town so
much wisdom happiness in this bookcase
the things that we've been tired watch
full bellies zombie space dinosaurs from
the deeper ate my family oh my god i
want to read that so bad that's creepy
hello that's creepy why is the music
stopped I don't like things in there
this window never got much attention
then again the view isn't nearly as
spectacular priorities right so look at
this picture did they have kids I used
to get wash in the sink apparently when
I was a little bit something draws me to
this trunk is it the memories locked
within well it's a trunk locks that is
probably the main reason you're just
thinking about treasure right everyone
was this treasure in trunks especially
lot trunks we all have our skeletons in
the closet but not Serena she was
perfect I doubt that everyone has their
flaws unfortunately even your lovely
Serena oh let's add Ord all things of
nature I remember her long walks out in
the will
college she's fairly religious not me
I'm the cold and cynical bastard but I
don't remember that ever being an issue
between us I miss her so much it's okay
how is it possible that I can't okay
face we'll get there in the end come on
come on we'll get there it is quite that
were greeting hozier a place of warmth
and passion Oh saggu of this side it's a
beautiful day though there's a natural
calm surrounding the area why is
unnatural if you're out in the woods
shorty Tom it's normal right Batson
Woodson trees nature nature I used it to
when shaving no idea there's a strand of
blonde hair in the comb she was blonde
dearest how do I say any of this I like
your way with words but if I don't write
this I don't know what I'll do I'll i
feel so unreal now dreamlike but
wonderfully so let me try even if
clumsily the hours I spent with you when
we last met her precious to me it was so
lost such a short time ago everything
seemed drained of color and feeling I
think we were meant to find each other
to bring meaning to our lives again
makes sense of the confusions shrouding
both of us when we stepped into the
crystal silence of the snowy woods away
from the chatter of the guests all
nature seemed expectant is it holding
its breath witnessing a rare moment of
something infinitely better than what
life in the ordinary run of things has
to offer do you remember how the light
crust of the snow glittered and the
reflected light of the country house how
the cops of trees in which we walked was
haloed with a magical aura I felt the
chill of the night air and you opened
your coat and unfolded me in your arms
and we hugged tight sharing the warmth
sharing the only thing any of us have to
share this earth and you think about it
what so um so were they just like a
one-night stand do you think listen I
have to remember her face I'm so
confused oh look you have some money
money money money okay these keys are
for the cabin and the car not for the
chest darn they prevent my blood
pressure from skyrocketing doctor's
orders and Serena's so you're like a
warrior oh you're you're an angry guy
commun avidolz Serena's favorite perfume
to unity dance I don't have a favorite
perfume result was that weird for a girl
Oh shows you her body art all of it hey
he shouldn't be reading this there's
been goats mm-hmm okay he can read a bit
that's a good as funny she was special
contradictory it's a hat she didn't mind
ease actually I think she was into them
too he's a very lucky man so he doesn't
say anything about this really weird
painting and the other one freaks me out
so much as I look at that like then
uribe about it why would you have that
if you're in a cabin in the woods you
don't want to see that on the wall and
then go outside and thought don't freak
out I would be a mess I'm sit with me I
want to talk and cuddle ok I am kind of
on edge because I heard that there was
one one part here I don't know where it
is for really any mission probably that
I heard that there is here remember last
time I 80 that is I don't feel badly
yeah I'm not vague about that and it's
just so quiet in this cabin Midas
awesome Serena that she doesn't need to
wear perfume her presence is magical
enough already
that just sounded like scary that didn't
her presence is magical party yes blonde
hair like Oh sun rays I'm remembering
goodbye with my memory did I have a
stroke hmm hmm she also had a brush
where how do I say any and then Utah
told us on the snow he devil we laughed
and rolled around my head already
spinning from the wine and crisp pure
night air and the stillness all around
we lay back and I guess when I realized
what I was seeing the luminous starscape
like a vast velvet cloth sprinkled with
powdered sugar like he can only be seen
in the countryside I had tears in my
eyes when I turned to you and we kissed
and it felt like the only moment in all
of time or outside time and ours was the
only spark that could ignite the
universe you gave me these moments you
complete me in ways I never need to
dream of let me be the one who makes
sense of the confusion whenever you feel
lost again we can make our own world
against the rest of the world if need be
together we can silence all the demons
heal all the wounds I love you in
eternity yours Serena I guess I'm a
total idiot and didn't realize that
there was more to that message but I'm
glad I knew it now okay I could only
remember what happened I can't help
these random associations it's always
been that way I look at a pepper shaker
and think of a Beatles song she loves
dude a guy okay long ago this was taken
on that crisp winter night at our mutual
friends hunting lodge we came back
indoors laughing giddy is teenagers it
was truly like an enchanted time like we
were in a magic circle where no sorrow
or pain could touch us
I love we don't have a lot of photos of
ourselves as a couple so this one is
quite important the guy who snapped this
our host that night used an actual film
camera it was a different world back
then so you've been skills quite well we
don't have a lot of photos of ourselves
as a couple so okay this music that's a
good thing now I can up in the chest is
there anything worse than beautiful
memories turning to dust I feel like I
don't even have the strength to lift the
lid okay outside perhaps won't
just as well stay here the outside is
calling you cannot hear the cameras this
window gets so backed up she's crying
there's crying open your closet oh it's
my general state of mind but I feel even
more depressing Arizona guess I can't
shake off be honest does this dress show
too much cleavage I want only one pair
of eyes on me now I miss her naked back
when she was standing by this one more
perfect curve of her head firm bottom I
should really stay cept higher anyway
there didn't seem to be much reason to
keep it clean just overgrown bushes
outside brambles missiles no no please
don't cry because it scares me Oh see
that's just the worst when the music
stops playing and it just goes that's
being sign it again after she cries I've
really hate that picture I'm thinking
where I've nightmares just a picture
where I so scared this isn't even
supposed to be like a terrifying game
prefer the darkness inside right here
but I wouldn't give it to get down to
everything to the plan no you shown that
once gave me so much joy now fills me
with unbearable sorrow why why big
enough for a lifetime with mementos
Mentos that you wrote let me see so what
is the point hey what is the point that
ticking it never stops well no because
it's a clock I've wasted so much time in
my life did I ever take a break to show
her how much I truly cared every day
look how did I miss everything getting
dinky earn more worn we should have
renewed our life somehow
money was always so tight the last thing
I need now is to see myself in the
mirror I must look awful take your pills
please she always reminded me to take
these I never asked her to she just did
it I've been so immature about these
even resorted to the old pill under the
tongue trick more than a few times help
me it's getting darker birdsong nothing
feels personal nope no chances anything
oh no he's getting angry as the day goes
on the stains on this bed suddenly make
me mad angry even she's okay okay um
you're okay
sit down We Need to Talk when did it go
so wrong this was supposed to be a we
weren't supposed to fight here you just
don't get it do you you never do all of
this these pathetic souvenirs from our
relationship they're all lies I couldn't
care less about this damn thing
torture myself trying to remember you
got too upset to even think straight i'm
gonna find out where she is so this is
me
talk
damn
I've been trying so hard but we lost
something along the way did you get my
letter yeah he got you now you just
listen to me for once god you're always
wait where are you going don't walk away
from me too upset to even think straight
I hate her so much I don't like he's
just getting really angry now and it's
so good it's obviously about that
relationship just breaking down line is
nobody's perfect I tell him this in the
beginning oh it's just a bunch of
schmaltzy junk what they caught again
yeah what are they code again ah camera
but it's cool I sit here on the train
taking me to my final farewell to the
ones who brought me to this world I see
the smiling couples on their way to new
adventures and think it used to be us we
had joy and laughter and friends once
but a memory is not the thing itself
you're very good at letting things you
don't want to face slip off you you
continue as if nothing has changed lost
in your own lifeless world words and
dreams may be enough for you you know
what you'll get a chance to test that
soon I question how I once saw things
how much of what I thought we had were
my own feelings and how much of your
manipulation because you are so very
good with words aren't you you knew how
to use them when we met in for the
longest time I went along with the
romantic whirl you conjured up around
our shabby isolated existence oh it took
me long enough to see it for what it was
and there were these moments that you
swept me off on foolish flights of fancy
when I threw myself into your fantasies
you wove your spell plying me with your
magic and with wine in equal measure and
I was taken in like the lost little girl
I was do you realize all the pain you've
caused me they say if you have to ask
whether someone loves you you already
know the answer protestations to the
contrary can no more convince me any
more than I can make my own mother or
father draw breath again your aloofness
tells a different story I no longer know
what you're thinking with my parents
gone and with your refusal to even
accompany me my time of need something
broke or maybe it happened long ago but
I never saw it so clearly before even
after
thing I don't make you feel comfortable
really that's all you have to say I
won't waste any more life waiting for
things that'll never come of course
that's what you expect me to do play The
Good Wife so known will laugh at you for
being the failure you are to shield you
from the truth of your existence lost in
your books and vapid verse blithely
drifting into the mists of time as if
not even a footnote when you could be
raking it it if you'd only use your
words for anything other than personal
indulgence you talked and talked about
your path the winter blueness of my eyes
all that nonsense and the years rolled
by the seasons came and went on and on
you pursuing your dreams that will never
be lost in your damned words looking for
clues you'll never find I'm sure you're
doing it even now with your rotting
books you took the best years of my life
and gave only empty words in return
we've gone as far as we can and
something's got to give us she's gone
now i remember it was me all the time I
lost her and it's all my fault she was
like yo phone like not trying to naivety
don't say anything else of value I
should tear all her filthy
disease-ridden clothes apart and burn
them I'm sure she's probably taking them
everything she wore just to lure me in
hey you just about there there was your
fault no wait I told you that it wasn't
your fault ok I don't want these violent
impulses give me the strength I need to
open the armoire what is wrong with me
too upset to even think straight I hey
look at your books oh my oh it's just
you're walking ah ah I don't know why
I'm so on edge she probably cared more
for this plant than she cared for me I'm
sure she uh I hate her so no one trying
to raise it with him did this be angry
together Jer are we finally sinking in
she's not coming back nothing in this
cabin will ever change again unless it's
by my hand
I hate her small of asst fees Oh what
was that like malicious what did I just
more lies my jewelry box what is it
doing here her wedding ring or mine but
what is it doing here well you broke up
didn't ease no I remember how happy
these made her she smiled that wonderful
smile I must have gifted these to make
amends or something or did i did i ever
gift her anything it's hers I can't
believe she would just leave it here
where the hell is she she's gone she's
on the train it can't be true no no I
didn't do it I need to wake up from this
nightmare Oh was my first guess right do
you think so care less about this damn
thing can you please open this now I
won't be very happy yeah what is it just
is it that she just closed that's always
gonna be like but there isn't gonna be a
pony and is it a pony oh my god I better
do it up
innervisions care
no no this isn't happening my god what
is this you can't it isn't how does it
happen I can't remember it's already
rotten beyond recognition how much time
has passed it's dry and withered a body
takes at least weeks to help how long is
it being sick is full sets of teeth I
can't even remember how I did it maybe I
didn't yes what do I have brain damage
honestly I wouldn't be surprised why did
it sound like the thought ah do you
realize how stupid this was we had a
plan I took measures to ensure nothing
like this would happen but knew you
couldn't help your damn self we can't
risk moving it now the bulldozers are
coming any minute fire will do it do you
think they will buy it after all this
time it's been months since you don't
worry it's all covered he spent much
time here see ghost is that he's funny
she killing him it's a girl but you're
lovely you should go out oh [ __ ] you
forgot your pop it was so stupid the
lies you do that why did you do that can
you calm down I couldn't bear to wear it
any longer it's in a safe place we'll
pick it from the ashes
oh that's it buddy no she's killing him
is that his body in the wardrobe am i
right why hey what he would tell me oh
my god oh that was so there was so crazy
that was so good I love games like that
I asked for me love games at that I
thought I was gonna be a jump-scare but
there wasn't which is good I was kind of
scared that's gonna be a jump scare but
as to startle you have to think about it
think about the story the whole time you
think that he's killed her but in the
end she's burning the evidence she
obviously cured him he's ghost Ryan like
yeah definitely she killed him and she's
religious oh my god right anyway I will
put this link in this description below
so you can have a play it's totally free
and it's let me know how you reacted to
this what you thought of this I thought
it was really creative really
imaginative really tense I'm really good
hope you enjoyed give it a thumbs up if
you did and a beloved air evening I
I hope the kid